number one job is to become more of
yourself and to grow yourself into the
best of yourself
I want to shatter these expectations and
belief systems right now in this video
but like I always say life is 10% what
happens to you is 90% what you do about
it rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message become
the-best-version-of-yourself over to you
Oprah Winfrey I have paid attention to
my life because I understand that my
life just like your life is always
speaking to you where you are in the
language with the people with the
circumstances and experiences that you
can understand and interpret if you are
willing to see that always life God is
speaking to you now it took me a while
to actually really get this and to
understand it but once I did I started
paying attention to everything and one
of the reasons why I can now accept the
fact that I can offer my gatherings of
information and wisdom and call myself a
spiritual teacher is that every single
person who ever came on my show and I
hear there was like thirty seven
thousand guests I've talked to a lot of
them came from dysfunction and a lot of
them wouldn't appear to be teachers but
every one of them had something to say
that was meaningful and valuable and
that I could use to grow myself into
the best of myself which is what all of
our jobs are your number one job is to
become more of yourself and to grow
yourself into the best of yourself I
think most people never find their
greatness I think everybody has Michael
Jordan level talent at something you
could be the Michael Jordan of something
and most people never find it most
people to come there were even close to
find it most people wake up and they
drive to a job that they hate so that
somebody else can build their dreams you
are working every single day so that
somebody else can build their dreams
instead of working on understanding
yourself and building your own dreams
and I think the starting point is if you
have no idea what you have Michael
Jordan level capabilities and that
should be your immediate goal your
immediate goal in life is figure out
what can you beat the Michael Jordan at
and there's three main ways that people
close himself off to learning that
really really really really hold
themselves back and I want to shatter
these expectations and belief systems
right now in this video the first is
that people often only want to learn
from people who look like them and
that's from a physical appearance like
men only want to learn from men they
won't respect learning from a woman why
people only want to learn from white
people black people only want to work
for black people
Asians only want other informations if
you restrict yourself to me being a
white guy to only learn from white guys
I'm never gonna reach my potential it's
never gonna happen in this video right
now we're learning from Oprah Winfrey
there's a white guy learning from a
black woman I love it if Oprah has a
message that can help me get better I'm
gonna embrace it now I may not be able
to relate to every message that she puts
out there but if she has a single
message that's gonna make me better I
want to hear it
I want to consume it and too many of you
are locked into only learning from
somebody who looks exactly like you and
that will limit your growth the second
thing you need to break through is if
you see one thing that you don't like
about somebody you write that entire
person off this is partly why I started
the top ten rules because I made a video
on Kanye West because people hate on
Kanye West because of all the things
that he does in public and his his
stunts and sometimes puts his foot in
his mouth and that's
fine you don't have to agree with that
but this is a lot you can still learn
from Kanye West to help you become
better if you cannot learn from Kanye
West because he does one or two or ten
things that you disagree with
then you're not putting him in a box
you're putting yourself in the box
you've put yourself in a box of how you
will grow and learn and just by that
very definition you're gonna get to
where you want to be so I have a big
poster of Steve Jobs on my wall in my
home office I love Steve Jobs for the
visionary but how he treated people I
don't want to learn to treat people like
Steve Jobs how he was a father he's not
gonna be my role model for that but to
be a visionary I love that thinking big
put a dent in the universe I love that I
can learn from that and so there may be
99 things that you hate about somebody
but if they've had success you can learn
that one thing that's what your goal is
your goal is not to be the next Steve
Jobs is to be the best version of you
and you get that by taking different
pieces from different people you could
be the Steve Jobs visionary and you can
be a great caring loving person right
you could be a great family person as
well and so you're taking one thing from
Steve Jobs and one thing from Seth Godin
and one thing from Oprah and one thing
from mother Teresa to make that unique
creature called you some people
complaining that I have somebody like
Jordan Belfort the wolf of Wall Street
on my channel we've done a couple videos
on him because he went to jail it's like
how could you make videos on somebody
who went to jail you're posting this guy
up as a role model in the videos that we
have of him all the messages are
positive right everything still gets put
through believe binoculars every message
is positive and yes Jordan Belfort did
things that were illegal and other
people have done illegal things on my
channel too and I'm not saying that that
is a good thing that you need to go off
and do but I am saying you can learn
from Jordan Belfort for example how to
sell you can learn a lot about how to
sell how to have confidence from Jordan
Belfort and then use those skills for
something positive use those skills or
something good and if you write off a
guy like Jordan Belfort and say well he
he committed a crime so I'm never gonna
learn from him he doesn't care you've
put yourself in a limited box of how
you're gonna learn
because that perfect person that you
want to learn from doesn't actually
exist if there's one person who could
teach you everything in life then the
best thing you're gonna be as a junior
version of them and never the full
version of yourself so you're taking
these pieces take something you can
learn from Jordan and discard the rest
same thing with the top ten rules I
learned something from every single
video that I put up but you don't have
to learn something from every ten if you
get one message out of the ten that
resonates with you and that shifts the
sparks and a difference for you that's
great that's a win and if the other nine
don't mean anything to you
throw them away who cares you're not
trying to be that first and you kind of
be a better you and so so many people
are just locked into one restricted way
of thinking and if one person is on one
little thing that they disagree what
they write off that person and all
you're really doing is writing off
yourself so change it change that
mindset immediately when you can learn
to learn from the people that you hate
the most
who've had success when you can find
something in the person you hate the
most
who's had success and find something you
can learn from them that's when you
really start to win and the third thing
that holds people back is just their
learning style if you can only learn
from one way of teaching then you're
also gonna be limited I had a call with
a guy who was trying to help me with my
business and there's supposed to be half
an hour talking about a project I'm
working on and as we got in the call I
recognized immediately some limiting
beliefs and so it ended up being the
whole call about him 45 minutes
all about him and I had the jet to go to
the next call because that was my hard
cap and so he spend zero time talking
about my project and everything talking
about him because that's what I do it's
believed I love it I'm not regretting
that decision we got back on a call
later on that afternoon and he said
thank you so much or I appreciate your
respective it really helped me and the
45 minutes of debating with you really
helped give me my perspective because I
learned through debate so that is your
problem that's what you need to fix
immediately because most people will not
have the patience to sit there with you
for 45 minutes to walk you through an
argument and if the only way you're
gonna learn is through debate then again
you have put yourself in a box
and you need to learn from multiple
paths even learning from your haters
learning if you guys make content you
guys put ideas out there you're gonna
get people who hate on your idea and
sometimes it's just pure negativity and
there's no point behind it but
oftentimes they're complaining about
something that is legit I made a video
about Jordan Peterson my first top 10
I'm Jordan Peterson
we made a video and my mic was broken
that day and so we made all the videos
for that month with us crazy echo in the
studio because we're picking up the
camera mic instead of my actual mic and
he might I hate that I got on that video
for the sound quality was out of control
and some of them were really nice about
it some of them were saying hey I love
your videos I don't know if you noticed
your microphone wasn't quite working
that day and some of the like this is
terrible the guy has all these
subscribers doesn't put any love into
his videos like you're in an echo
chamber dude it sounds like you're in a
washroom just just dump and hate but it
comes from a place up there right right
like if I see negativity and refuse to
learn from it then I put myself in the
box and I will never grow so if you can
only learn from one style you can only
learn through the baiting or if you can
only learn when somebody sugarcoats
everything for you and gives it to you
in a you're- medicine with a spoonful of
sugar right if it's the only way you're
gonna take input your Guth will be so so
so insanely slow and so I think your
ultimate goal my ultimate goal is to be
able to be the best version of yourself
whatever that looks like
right Michael Jordan level talent at
something and go have that kind of
impact you can do that for your industry
for something and most people have no
idea how to get there most people
haven't even started and a lot of it is
because they have a learning style where
they only want to learn for people who
look like them they only want to learn
from people who have never done anything
wrong at all they agree 100% with what
this person always does and then they
only have one learning style of they
have to be walked through it they have
to debate or they have to do it their
way and that's the only way they're ever
gonna learn and so because of all these
restrictions it means they never learn
and you never figure out who you could
be
and so my goal with this entire channel
is to bring you diversity bring you
different ideas bringing people from
different backgrounds athletes
entrepreneurs inventors singers
politicians who all are pointing at the
same thing in the hopes that finally you
get the message and for people from
different races and religions and
backgrounds and gender because maybe you
finally hear it in some way if you hear
it enough times over and over and over
again from different people it finally
clicks but I encourage you to examine
your own life and see where your blocks
are how are you putting yourself in a
box and how is that limiting you because
I guarantee you you don't become the
Michael Jordan by living in a box it's
not gonna happen and I desperately want
you to break free now I've got a really
special bonus tip for you but before
that I want to know which of those three
learning blocks do you feel most
resonates with you do you feel like you
only learn from people who look like you
do you feel like if somebody does one
thing that you disagree with you write
that person off as a person refuse to
learn from them or do you have a
preferred learning style that then hold
you back from learning in different ways
or is there some combination of all of
them leaving the comments below and I
hope my sincere hope is that by writing
it down you also release it that you're
writing it down you recognize that this
is limiting me this is my box and I want
to release it out into the world so
write it down the comments below I want
to help you release it thank you guys so
much for the love I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of an espresso and
enjoy the bonus clip
expresso give me go
well I'm stuck in a rut because I can't
seem to follow through with anything I
went to college for a year and a half
and I dropped out then I went to
cosmetology school I completed that but
I never went back to get my license then
I was a pharmacy technician and I
recently let that license expire as well
I just see like so many people that are
my age and they're already setting their
careers and I just feel like at 29 I'm a
people person so I want to do something
like Human Resources and I just need
help like where do I begin first of all
you're talking about stuff that I can
relate to like so many others can relate
to I mean you know everybody got the
same story we just got different details
but like I always say life is 10% what
happens to you is 90% what you do about
it see we're gonna dive into a chapter
from my new book and it's chapter 1
section 1 this is very clear for people
so the first step is getting completely
and brutally honest enough to say I am
tired of myself when you say I'm sick
and tired of being sick and tired
that's the facilitator of change that's
when you're ready to say these words no
more excuses no more excuses I went to
Kent State I dropped out upward and drop
out of flunked out now that threw my
life into a spiral but because I didn't
have a college degree I could not let
that stop me and like you're doing were
you saying all my friends at this age
are settling in your careers you don't
even know if they happy or not stop
comparing yourself to others so the
first thing you do is stop focusing on
other people instead focus on being the
best version of you that you can then
you'll recognize that you deserve to sit
at the big table with everybody else
after you become the best that you can
be now once you've accepted that you
have as much right to success and much
right to succeed as anybody else the
next step is learning how to talk the
talk you have to get fluent in the
language of success so you speak it with
ease
surround yourself with people who've
accomplished their dreams and immerse
yourself in the culture of achievement
the notion that we are not enough is a
lie and I think more young people need
to know that that like when you have
that thought that you're not enough that
that's based on a lie that somebody said
to you or so or a lie that somebody did
to you like somebody said or did
something to you to make you feel like
you're not enough and that's not true
that you are everything that you need to
be that you have everything that you
need to have to be the person that
you're meant to be and to be the best
version of who you're meant to be it may
mean that you have to work really hard
and it may mean that you have to ask for
help but you are perfectly blessed you
know you are exactly who you're supposed
to be to be joyful in this life so don't
be afraid to work hard and don't be
afraid to ask for help so you can get
there because that's your truth I was
different I still am different I'm in a
country which is very far far away from
home very far away from familiarity and
I think that's what my strengths are
[Music]
when I was young I didn't understand
that when I was a kid in school when I
was bullied when I didn't understand who
I was turning into but what makes you
different if you identify that and you
realize that all right this is what's
different about me if you think about it
that's exactly what makes us special
that's exactly what makes you unique and
you need to just and I did that over
time be the best version of yourself
because the more different you are the
most special you are raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
we believe that people with passion and
not one drop of myself work depends on
your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or absolutely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten Rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details